operators get ready for the final round
ash you can always pick her she has
three ash breaches good weapon etc
and that's why her presence in the game
is so high and always has been
they don't have to peak this too much
this is going to wait until it gets in
the crossfire and pango gets one
bengal
[Music]
her flashes would have 100 cemented her
in the s tier but she's still in there
three ash charges
three breach charges basically a goddamn
sledge basically like just
you could do so much destruction you can
get rid of everything in the goddamn map
with ash
it's all two v3s all down to hicks and
you know the defuser will go down in the
back of arsenal
but shocked but with a great kill onto
hicks we'll try and get another one get
instantly traded out by uno
it's all down to him in a 1v2 post blind
he has the plan down and he has the
kills he gets another shepherd and then
with a
[Applause]
now
[Applause]
all right folks before we get into the
video i want to make sure you are all
sub to the channel so please
if you aren't subbed already hit the sub
button and click on the notification
bell it really does make a difference
anyway ash has been part of rainbow six
siege since the very beginning
takes down cato judas is the last man
standing he gets two
gets for a third as he reaps over the
top and suddenly it's a 1v2
as one of the game's 20 original
operators ash was designed as an
aggressive entry fragger who was
supposed to breach the enemy's defenses
within the first few moments of a round
hell ash's in-game war even has another
character call her miss kick in the door
the destruction capability on ash is
ridiculous and the fragging capability
as well because
you know three speed ash to help ashe
live up to a reputation
she was given a pretty significant
advantage her
gun which is one of the best in the game
according to disrupt gaming this gun is
meant for entry fragging and is meant
with competing with smgs in close
quarters
that's what ash was designed for to take
these close quarter gunfights and win
them and open picks for her team so
this gun aids perfectly with that it is
the best
entry fragging assault rifle probably in
the game with its high rate of fire
strong damage and low recoil the r4c
assault rifle was the holy grail of
siege weapons all on its own
but when paired with the acog sight and
its 2.5 time zoom
it was arguably the definition of
overpowered
oh counter right next to eunice get them
through the wall
but uh eunice get wilkie just before
that they have
the oh with the double kill right after
headshot after headshot for this guy in
its heyday this
deadly combination made ash good at
pretty much everything
she was like miss do it all at one point
like [ __ ] stuns a really good gun
fast like small hitbox so she could do
everything herself literally
ash could bust in guns blazing or hold
angles from afar
it didn't matter what you did with her
she was basically unstoppable
i'm in the objective quick everyone
follow me
go go
picking ash made you look like an
[ __ ] to both teams in your lobby
you would either hard carry your team
and slaughter every enemy within the
first 20 seconds of the round
or leroy jenkins your way onto the site
and die immediately
ashmane no brain is a thing for a reason
how does this keep happening of course
having a character that powerful in the
operator pool pretty much guaranteed
that ash's pick rate would be
ridiculously high across
all levels of play i think the people
who like her they like her because
she's a very very very entry level and
extremely easy operator
you have a very basic job that you need
to do and it's easy to get attached to
something that's easy and
still performs really well s can in the
game some of the best utility in the
game
and the best speed in the game why they
put it on all three of those things on
one op
i don't know ash became the de facto
queen
of siege but she was about to lose
her crown jewel
[Music]
over the years ubisoft devs have tried
and kind of failed to make ash more
balanced
all right hold down the trigger till you
get a headshot boys that's how you play
ash
hey he headshot there were a couple of
persistent myths about her
first that she was faster than any other
character in the game
and don't try to tell me all three
speeds at the same speed because that's
like saying all water tastes the same
alright
just not true and second that her head
hitbox was
somehow smaller than all the other
operators
that's just straight up ash does not
have a hitbox
that's all that is multiple players
claimed that ash came at them like a
headless blur
whipped out her overpowered assault
rifle and sent them into the siege
afterlife all while they were
desperately clicking on her head
and hitting the wall behind her
what kitchen garage last night main
stairs
oh my god what is wrong with ash
turns out ash's head hitbox was actually
smaller than some of the other operators
but she certainly wasn't the only one
the women hitboxes
are technically smaller um but again
it's
pixels that we're talking in in terms of
differences but it can't matter
siege is a very precise game so as for
how quickly she moved as a three-speed
operator
ash was fast sure but not any faster
than the other characters in that
category as youtuber nukemdukem pointed
out
you know how three-speed is king like
you know you had ella
you had ash high fast moving operators
it seems like they have a huge advantage
to people who have
one speed but three armor ubisoft tried
to adjust ash's speed and hit boxes but
she stayed just as popular and broken as
ever
he tried to meme on you a lot of people
pointed to her gun as the problem
many in the community felt that the r4c
having an acog site made it too powerful
and ubisoft listened they removed the
acog as a customization option for the
rifle
heading into year 4 season 1 of the game
and sure
in the landscape of strategic gameplay
and tactical picks ash's brain dead
approach went against
everything that siege stood for but the
r4c in acog combo
was what made ash well ash
i mean i was one of the people who told
ubisoft to remove the ash ago like
i don't care i mean i thought it was too
powerful for people that see this and
know me for long it's been a long time
coming this is something i've been
wanting for years and ironically it
happens when i retire they finally nerf
her
ash has an acog and she always has had
an acog
and she always will have an acog
at first the nerf made people move off
of ash but by the next season
she was right back to where she started
a lot of women that's for sure oh
nice shot from bibu just seems like he
plays the ash and runs it well
the two heavy fraggers so far are taken
away but they're still rask and that's
another one for bibu
all you need to do is just put a drone
in front of this ash and bibi will just
frag out of his mind so once again
ubisoft returned to nerfing ash
in operation north star the devs took
away one of her breaching rounds and
increased the r4c's recoil
and ash's pick rate plummeted
yeah ash is our first he definitely has
a new recoil was that in
that was not in the patch notes right no
it wasn't bro
yeah bro this it's done we're done for
i'm done take away your crutch huh
people are going to be
very very very very very very mad there
were now
other operators out there with easier to
control guns and
overall better utility and while the
change was mostly aimed at pro-level
players
the nerf was felt all across the board
for as long as it's been around rainbow
six siege has always been a work in
progress
constantly evolving and changing to stay
balanced and fun
sure ash was a comfort pick for new
players but she was also an operator
that experienced pros could frag out
with
while it might be disappointing for some
taking away just a bit of ash's insane
versatility
will give other operators a chance to
shine and shake up the meta in a way
that can only be good for siege in the
long run
i really feel like the devs have had a
focus on uh
increasing uh skill ceilings while still
maintaining skill floors where they are
but just making it so that like we can
truly like differentiate who's a good
player or who's used up using a
very very easy weapon to use so i i
think with these patches they've really
like managed to put
more and more skill expression in the
game which i think
long term is going to be extremely
healthy for the game but no matter what
happens with ash in the future
she was already successful at arguably
the most difficult balancing act of all
walking the fine line between
mind-blowing courage
and mind-numbing aggression thanks for
watching
if you want more content like this hit
the sub button and ring that
notification bell
for unique bite size videos you won't
find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages
you